we finished the last video with the
scenario where company a wants to buy
Company B but they're not going to do it
with cash they're going to do it with
their shares so the issue a press
release saying that Company A intends to
acquire Company B for sixty million
dollars in A's shares and they want to
give it a price they want to give a
price that's a premium to company B's
current market cap so that it's
compelling so that the shareholders of
Company B want to do it it's like wow
that's a that's a twenty percent premium
to our current market cap so we're
willing to do it but since this is a
share transaction Company B shareholders
won't exactly get sixty million dollars
what's going to happen is Company A is
going to issue two million in new shares
those two million new shares in theory
could be worth $30 a share maybe they
could sell them in the open market at
$30 a share so that they would be worth
sixty million dollars but instead of
trying to raise the cash and then giving
the cash to Company B they're just going
to take those shares directly and
exchange them for all of the shares of
Company B essentially acquiring the
company with all of those shares so
every shareholder of Company B for every
share they have they'll get two shares
of Company A so if at the time of
closing company a's stock price goes
from thirty to thirty five dollars a
share then the transaction price would
if you think about the market value of
those shares that company B's
shareholders are going to get the market
price would actually be seventy million
dollars if the trends if the market
price of Company A goes down to twenty
five dollars a share then they're only
going to be they're only going to get
they're only going to get 50 million
dollars worth of shares but what I want
to think about in this situation is what
should happen to company B's stock
before the transaction closes while if
we assume that everyone thinks the
transaction is going to happen so let's
let me draw a stock chart here so this
is price that is price this is time
right over here time and let's let me
draw a company B's stock price first so
let's say right now it is trading at $50
a share that is company B and right now
Company A is trading at $30 a share
Company A is trading at $30 a share
notice even though that their share
price is lower than Company B share
price they have a much larger market cap
because they have many many more shares
so they actually are a larger company so
it doesn't sound crazy for them to
acquire Company B now at the time this
is the day that everything was announced
and let's just assume let's just assume
that everyone thinks the transaction
will happen so for every share of be a
be shareholder has they will get two
shares of company a so if company a if
company a does this what should happen
to company B's stock price if everyone
is a hundred percent sure the
transaction is going to happen well
every shareholder of B is going every
share of B is going to be converted into
two shares of a so after this point in
time if you're sure the transaction is
going to happen each of these B shares
should be worth two a shares so they
should trade exactly at twice the value
of the a shares so right when the
transaction is announced if everyone
assumes it's going to occur B shares
should immediately jump up to should
immediately jump up to $60 a share and
then they should always trade they
should always trade at double of a
shares if they trade at less than double
of a's shares then instead of buying a
shares people would rather buy b shares
because b or they could buy half of B
shares or let's say there was someone
who's going to buy two of a shares
instead they'll say hey look B shares
are trading for less than two of a
shares but they're going to be worth two
of a shares in the future because of
this merger so I'm just going to buy B
shares instead so there's there's no
reason if everyone assumes the
transactions happen that before the
transaction closes that B shouldn't
trade at exactly twice the stock price
of a